-Our next guest is
a Grammy nominated comedian
who's latest special
"Hello, World"
is streaming now on Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
-So, one part
of your brain is smart
and the other part is dumb.
You can trick your own brain.
That's how dumb
the dumb part is.
[ Laughter ]
It's in the same head.
That's embarrassing.
It's like, you don't
hear this going on, dude?
If you're in a bad mood,
they tell you to fake smile
and your dumb part
will think it's a good day.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you don't hear
the planning going on?
Like, you're a part
of the planning.
-Please welcome to the show
the very funny Nate Bargatze.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, Nate!
-Hey. Thank you, man.
-I've been a fan
for a long time.
I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm excited to be here, dude.
This is fun.
-You're from Tennessee,
you live in Tennessee,
but you you spent a fair amount
of time here in New York City.
-Yeah, I lived here for
eight and a half years,
like, 2004 to '12.
-And what were your first
impressions of the city?
-It was great. It's a lot, Dude.
I mean, it's such a different
thing coming from Tennessee,
like, haven't left.
I remember first seeing when
people parallel parked,
like, they bump cars, you know?
And me, I saw it and I was like,
I'm watching a hit and run.
I watched -- I wrote their
license plate down.
I was gonna call the NYPD,
who's probably the most buys.
And just be like, "You won't
believe what's going on."
And, like, I mean, I thought
it was like a giant thing,
and then you just learn
that's what --
that's what everybody does.
That's what bumpers are for.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Yeah.
-That's -- We were like,
"Nope that's what they're for."
-I actually became
unbelievable at it,
and I remember I one time parked
and mine was touching two cars.
So I got real good.
I though, it fits --
If we can do it, I will do it.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-If there's a skill
out there to be learned,
you might as well learn it.
Now, I'm surprised
that you had this skill.
A lot of people
I think know this now,
but when you're an early
comedian in the city,
one of the things you do
to get stage time
is you go out and you
sort of are a comedy barker,
you try to get people
to go to shows.
And sometimes if you're walking
around, certainly, like,
Times Square, you see really
enthusiastic young comedians
trying to convince people.
You did that.
You don't quite have
that barker vibe.
-Yeah, it's this energy...
-Yeah.
-...that's just like,
"Hey, you wanna come --"
I wouldn't even do that.
"You wanna, like,
come to this comedy show?
And people were like, "No."
Like, they would
grab the flyer --
It was at Boston Comedy Club,
it was called New York,
and they would get the flyer
and just drop it
in front of me.
Like ju-- It was almost like
they just wanted to litter.
Like, they could have
just said no.
But they were like, they just
wanted me to pick it up.
-They wanted to
save other people
from having to be
asked this question.
-They grabbed them all
and they threw them.
They go, "Just go.
Move back home."
-This last special is wonderful.
We were talking backstage.
I think we have
very similar wives.
Your wife seems to know
how everything works,
very helpful around the house.
I don't know anything.
You make a great show
of the fact that
you don't know anything.
And a boiler guy showed up
at you house.
and I've had this happen
before where they assume
that you're the guy
with the information.
-Yeah, we say "water heater."
-Okay.
-So, boiler, I didn't even know
what you're talking about.
So, I mean,
I don't know what's happening.
But we, yeah, in the special,
I talk about how our
water heater broke
and the guy who came over
was asking me where it was.
And I don't know where --
Like, I was like, I don't know.
And -- 'Cause it's like, I would
just walk by at the wrong time.
A lot of times when --
'Cause she has people over
there,
just coming over
and doing stuff.
She's always fixing something.
And they talk to me.
And, like, I keep,
like, looking.
I'm like -- And she answers.
But they keep looking at me.
I'm like, what are you
not getting, dude?
Like, I don't know
these answers.
We have a new roof.
And I found out
from my neighbor.
A whole new roof.
[ Laughter ]
I was, like, out in the
driveway, he goes,
"How's the new roof?"
And I go, "What's that?"
And then she went and got
a new roof when I was gone,
and I didn't even --
There was no, like, heads up.
Like, I'm not in --
Like, it didn't matter.
It's not like I'm gonna
live differently.
[ Laughter ]
But I was --
It's embarrassing, you know,
to be sitting there
and be in my 40's.
-I also, I mean, it seems like
you're the same way as me.
Like, I would assume if my wife
decides we need a new roof,
I agree, right?
-Yeah, oh yeah.
-I would never put my foot down
and be like,
"There -- Not on my --"
"This roof is the roof
we're gonna have."
-No, I would -- Yeah.
I stay out, and I would like to.
I would like to do that,
to go, like,
"Over my dead body,
are we gonna get a new roof."
I love this roof so much.
[ Laughter ]
I don't even know how to tell
if a roof's bad.
Like, I don't --
[ Laughter ]
Like, I mean, if it's just gone,
you know?
-If water poured in,
I would say we need a new roof.
But other than that...
-If she told me we don't,
I would say okay.
Like, I would be like,
"Well, she knows."
-Yeah.
-You know?
-She's like,
"Oh, this is a bucket.
You just get
a bucket for this."
-You're like, "All right."
-"Where's the buckets?"
That's where? I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- But this is --
You used to read,
so I'm surprised you don't know
about a water heater,
'cause you used to do --
You were a meter reader. Yes?
-A water meter reader.
-Water meter reader.
-Yes.
And, so, when I first started,
like, this is the job I had.
This is the job I'll go back to
when all this falls apart.
-Okay.
This is a Tennessee job?
-This is a Tennessee,
Wilson County,
we read water meters, so,
like, you know, to see, like,
how much water you used,
and you get billed for it.
And, so, it was in 2001
and it was when 9/11 happened.
So right after 9/11 happened,
they got worried that they were
gonna come after our water
at Wilson County --
the terrorists.
And...
[ Laughter ]
So, we --
This is all we --
For one year,
we would take shifts
and you would guard
the water towers.
And we spent the night just
begging the Taliban to try.
[ Laughter ]
Just --
Come get in Mount Juliet's
water, dude.
You gonna have the nerve
to poison Wilson County's water?
Not on our watch.
We were out there all night
in the woods waiting for them.
-Yeah.
-Well, it was effective.
They didn't --
Word got back to them.
They didn't come near it.
-Ah, water's been great.
-Yep.
-It's been great.
-You, uh, you do tell a lot
of jokes about your wife.
I should note,
she comes out always...
I mean, you tell 'em.
You know.
She comes out
a lot smarter than you.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-Makes it helpful,
but do you run everything
by her ahead of time?
-Yeah, she knows everything.
Like, I tell her --
Like, she knows all the jokes
that I'm gonna say.
Like, I don't want to surpri--
Like, you know,
say anything mean, or, like,
you know, stuff like that.
So she knows all the jokes, and
she's got a sense of humor of,
like, she likes making fun, too.
So it works that I can say the
stuff and I let her hear it.
I may have one joke --
I don't have one,
but it's like, if one was great,
though, it would be tough.
Like, 'cause it's like, how hard
it is to get a good joke.
If she's like,
"I don't like that one,"
I was like, "Ah, it gets
a pretty big applause, so..."
Like, I don't know.
-"I mean, I did get you
a new roof."
-I'd go -- Yeah!
I'd go, "We'll get another one!
We'll get two roofs!"
-Yeah, you want one?
-Might as well put another one
on top of it. Double it up."
-Double the roof.
-Why aren't more people
not doing more roofs?
You should do two roofs.
-You have a daughter.
-Yep.
-Does -- Who gets
the laughs at home?
Does your --
Is your daughter funny?
Does she think you're funny?
-I don't think she --
I mean, she gets that
people think I'm funny,
but she'd very funny.
And she -- And I like it 'cause
she'll get my wife going,
and then once my wife starts
laughing, like, our daughter,
she just doesn't let up.
It's like a show.
So, it's, like, very fun to see,
like she just gets it,
and she's like, all right, I got
her, and it just keeps rolling.
She does, like, she does voices,
like very more
talented than I am.
Like, I'm just this.
[ Laughter ]
-Well --
-She can -- all over the place.
-Well, next generations
sometimes are.
It's a 2.0 situation.
I remain a very big fan
of what you do on stage.
Thank you so much
for being here, man.
What a pleasure to meet you.
-Absolutely.
-You guys, that's Nate Bargatze.
"Hello World" is streaming now
on Prime Video.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night"